this is not a total lockdown at least
not yet but it is containment flights in
and out of Beijing are being limited to
curb a new outbreak and stopped an
unnerving ripple becoming a second wave
those leaving here have to choose from a
per wheel during option of QR codes for
each city they scan them on their phones
to prove they haven't been anywhere at
high risk people are protecting
themselves and their children and some
current leave soon enough I'm leaving
because this outbreak is quite serious
and I'm afraid of being infected I want
to escape and go back home yes
on balance I am afraid because this
virus is a scary thing and we don't know
anything about it I only use
taxi-hailing apps when I go out now
so of course I'll be safer at home the
current outbreak began in this wholesale
market in the southwest of the city and
the outbreak has only just started
officials warned confirmed cases have
been isolated in one hospital only one
case is critical and just a handful are
severe contacts are being traced and
tested on a huge scale with more than
350,000 tests so far this was the line
for tests today all the schools have
been shut and some residential compounds
have been sealed off but this isn't like
the Wuhan lockdown in January cars are
still allowed on roads and the Beijing
traffic has a matter
and the underground remains open even if
today it wasn't very busy for Russia
commuters perhaps taking extra
precautions danger spots like bars
though have been told to close this
employee told us the government had
ordered him to stay shot for a month
closed empty restaurants may be a
familiar sight but here a few days ago
these bars were buzzing and full of
people there hadn't been a case in
Beijing for 56 days before this latest
outbreak instead they be relying on apps
like this to track people's movement to
keep things under control what this
shows is that absent a covert 19 vaccine
there is no knockout blow instead you've
got to roll with the punches and react
and it is an aggressive reaction given
the relatively small number of cases the
Chinese Communist Party has boasted of
his success in containing ko bid 19
especially as the West has floundered
here in the capital of all places that
success must continue top Cheshire Sky
News Beijing